in this video we are going to discuss
about the fight between godzilla and
kong
that will be seen in the upcoming movie
and what will happen if godzilla is
killed in the battle
we will see the consequences thereafter
and what kong would have to face up
against
if such a situation occurs note that
in this theory godzilla isn't
necessarily killed by kong
but maybe by mecha godzilla or even the
oxygen destroyer weapon if it is ever
used again
in the movie which is really highly
unlikely we know that this is a very
controversial topic and we will
follow up with a video of what if gong
dies in godzilla vs kong
so subscribe if you haven't and hit that
bell button
for more regular updates on more
godzilla vs gong dissection videos
so let's do it so godzilla the nuclear
lizard
the atomic [ __ ] slap monster does look
more or less the same
in the trailers as he did on the last
movie king of the monsters
he seems to retain the same height of
393 feet
tall or almost 120 meters but the weight
will only be known when the official
statistics are revealed
but he is one of the most powerful
monsters in the master verse if not the
strongest
all in all he has lived through or
survived mass extinction events
ancient battles with the species of
kongs and others
battles against the murals the muto
prime the
a fall from the upper atmosphere
defeated ghidorah in the past and then
killed ghidorah in kotm
he seems a bit all too powerful but is
he now
titanic's gojira might seem to live on
for millions of years
but they are not immortal at least they
might be biologically immortal but they
can die from grievous wounds and
parasite exposed that feed on them from
within
and godzilla himself nearly died a
couple of times in king of the monsters
once when he was hit by the oxygen
destroyer weapon and second when he was
choked unconscious and dropped from the
upper atmosphere by monster zero
ghidorah if that doesn't convince you
then the monster was slower states that
many of these
members of titan's gojira fell under the
hands of the mutos
and the muta prime most notably dagon
the one seen in the opening scenes of
godzilla 2014
but in this fight against kong and most
probably mechagodzilla
would the g-man survive and if not what
will happen to the world
theories and supposedly leaked plots are
out there in the
internet saying that godzilla will
battle against kong in the ocean and
there will be no clear winner
like a stalemate and then they will
again meet in the final battle
after they fight other tyrants and
creatures and in this battle it is said
that kong would lose
the fight by a margin of a margin and
that at that time
when both are worn out and exhausted
mechagodzilla will appear
and overpower godzilla but then kong
saves the day by joining the fight
and both win and go on their own
separate ways but what if legendary
pulls the wool
over our eyes and decides to kill
godzilla
so what if godzilla dies supposedly kong
gets the upper hand and beats the g-man
by a margin of a margin
as well and godzilla gives out and dies
then kong as the sole survivor now has
to contend with a fully charged mecha
godzilla
with all its weapons and cybernetics to
actually counter
the only advantage that gom had over
godzilla his intelligence and agility
mechagodzilla would make minced meat out
of the battered kong
and this would also mean the death of
kong
ghidorah's consciousness then would
maybe take over the mechanized titan and
with both the species of kong and
godzilla now extinct
there would be no more challenger the
natural world would now fall under the
reign of the unnatural and the space
monster anyway what would the other
titans do in such a case
the most probable theory is that these
super species would once again obey the
alpha call of ghidorah
sounded out through the body of mecca
godzilla any attempts to regain control
over the mechanized titan by humans
would fail
and they would be targeted for
destruction of course unlike godzilla
the other titans might be susceptible to
nuclear attacks
and hence humans might kill one or two
of these
gigantic beasts at but at a huge cause
for humanity in the process
there is also the likelihood of skull
crawlers
warbats and other new titans from the
hollow earth and that they would
resurface and turn the world into their
domain once more
don't take this as gospel it is just a
theory and even if godzilla dies
there might be a godzilla junior in the
depths who knows
well with this we have come to the end
of the video do like for support
share it with your godzilla and gong
friends debate over
it come back with a good reply in the
comment section and then subscribe
if you haven't and slap slap slap that
bell button for regular updates
till the next one take care fam
you